[Musique]
premier numéro du 7-8 ecosur téléphiles
à 60,18 merci de nous rejoindre tous les
quinze jours nous évoquerons une
nouvelle à thématique et en ce mois de
septembre nous verrons que les
entreprises de saint quentin en yvelines
dispose d'un important vivier de
potentiels collaborateurs entreprises
les étudiants de 50 ans sont peut-être
vos futurs salariés voici le sommaire en
images le 12 septembre françois hollande
était en déplacement à saint quentin en
yvelines il a visité les locaux et dit
fuck up l'institut de formation
commerciale permanente à l'occasion pour
le chef de l'état a évoqué la mise en
place du plan gouvernemental 500000
formation supplémentaire de l'institut
supérieur du management de l'université
de versailles-saint-quentin des livres à
travers cette mention depuis 2010 des
formations de niveau licence et master
le but de ce pool permettra à ses élèves
d'intégrer plus facilement le monde du
travail via sa filière d'alternance et
en plateau pour ce premier numéro et
juan magan bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
conseiller communautaire de saint
quentin délégué à l'emploi on va essayer
de voir avec vous si justement en termes
d'emplois notamment pour les cadres
l'offre coïncide avec la demande et puis
il y à l'agglomération qui justement
elle vient de lancer vous allez le voir
en images une grande enquête auprès des
dirigeants afin de mieux recenser leurs
besoins plusieurs rendez vous sont
prévus c'était donc à maurepas pour ce
premier rendez vous quel est l'objectif
de cette enquête alors l'enquète et pour
savoir précisément ce que souhaitent les
grands comptes et les pme concernant
leur recherche de collaborateurs voilà
et puis qui ça fonctionne bien son
territoire entre l'offre et la demande
cette enquête est vraiment importante
puisque mi octobre nous allons préparer
un grand séminaire avec différents
partenaires institutionnels
donc ces petits déjeuners plus le
questionnaire on nous permettent
d'alimenter des ateliers et puis aussi
de répondre à leurs demandes parce que
leur demande on à repérer déjà ce matin
un certain nombre d'éléments la semaine
prochaine l'agenda d'autres petits
déjeuners il y aura encore d'autres
demandes par rapport à ça il va falloir
réguler de savoir ce qu'est ce qui est
prioritaire qu'est ce qui l'est moins en
tous les cas ce qui est vraiment
important c'est que les entreprises du
territoire trouve chaussure à leur pied
ce que me permettre par rapport à leurs
demandes d'emploi c'est difficile
aujourd'hui justement pour une
entreprise de trouver des collaborateurs
qui réside sur saint quentin en yvelines
assure toutes les entreprises il ya des
secteurs d'activité ça fonctionne bien
ils seront peut-être les secteurs les
plus compliquées alors les secteurs les
plus compliqués c'est tout ce qu'il ya à
main d'oeuvre voilà tout simplement et
puis on oublie souvent l'artisan la
petite tpe la petite pme mais ce que pme
ça va jusqu'à 200 300 salariés mais ceux
qui ont cinq six salariés qui se
développe autour de maurepas puisque si
c'est un bassin de vie je fréquente
régulièrement il est élu à maurepas
aussi je l'aimais tant a précisé mon
ambition c'est aussi une tpe qui démarre
à trois salariés qui en team croissance
à 8 9 salariés il est bien évident que
le chef d'entreprise un temps de
recherche d'emploi c'est 30% sur une
semaine il est bien évident que c'est
compliqué pour eux donc ils font appel à
des aides extérieures mais effectivement
sur des secteurs comme les secteurs
marchands de main d'oeuvre pur c'est
très compliqué mais comment
l'agglomération comment les politiques
peuvent justement intervenir pour
faciliter cette mise en relation entre
les demandes d'emploi et les demandeurs
d'emploi alors
vous savez que j'ai une fibre libérale
alors vous savez aussi que le politique
s'immiscer dans tout ce qui est lié au
public en tout cas moi j'ai c'est un peu
compliqué pour moi mais faut s'enlever
deçà de la tête parce que il est
clairement évident que pôle emploi ne
peut pas tout faire pour l'emploi sur le
bassin de saint quentin est une très
bonne à une très bonne dynamique c'est
indéniable on se croise on discute on
met des choses en place nous ce que nous
devons voir entendre politique et
comprendre c'est que il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses d'acteurs sur le
territoire qui font qu'ils veulent bien
faire et qui font bien mais vous avez
tellement con excité sur le territoire
de portes d'accès à l'emploi à
l'insertion c'est que entre celui qui
cherche et celui qui demande on ne sait
plus où je crois que là on doit unifier
notre énergie avec une seule l'unique
porte d'entrée en collaboration avec
pôle emploi c'est pas faire en plus de
pôle emploi c'est pas faire à la place
de pôle emploi non plus saint quentin en
yvelines ne manque pas de centre
formation et écoles dans des domaines
très variés regarder cette carte tout
d'abord l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines implantée à
guyancourt à montigny aussi à qui
dispense aussi bien des formations seo
humaine endroit qui dispose aussi de son
observatoire de l'atmosphère terrestre
on en a souvent parlé sur notre antenne
il ya aussi le lycée d'hôtellerie et de
tourisme à guyancourt pour le bâtiment
les travaux publics le cfa est située
sur trappe à voisins le bretonneux un
cfa dédié à l'automobile et puisqu'on
parle d'automobiles le véhicule de
demain est aussi au coeur des
enseignements dispensés à l'estaca à
montigny et puis à plaisir le nôtre où
l'on forme les pâtissiers de demain on
efface tout de même et c'est un luxe à
une très grande richesse sur ce bassin
de saint quentin en yvelines dans tous
les domaines oui c'est un atout
véritablement pour le territoire oui
d'accord
ça très bien bref vous avez fini
cartographie alors beaucoup de
noms mais c'est un clin d'oeil parce que
j'ai demandé à 50 ans de me faire une
cartographie donc on est en plein en
plein réflexion là dedans et vous savez
que depuis mode février nous avons
rencontré au moins ou plus d'une
douzaine de centres de formation est ce
que vous venez de dire et de citer j'ai
rencontré les directeurs je suis allé
voir et cci sur la chambre des métiers
d'artisanat nous avons rencontré un
certain nombre d'acteurs et
effectivement c'est très varié mais les
métiers de bouche par exemple n'ont pas
les mêmes problématiques que les métiers
des nouvelles technologies s'adapter à
chaque centre il faut s'adapter il faut
quand même pas se leurrer quand même et
il faut pas se mentir il ya des ports
industriels qui sont en train de
s'effondrer et il ya des points
industriels qui sont en train d'émerger
l'aï technologies il faut y penser voilà
donc ça c'est des nouveaux pans de
métier des nouveaux métiers auxquels il
faut vraiment être en veille sur la
formation reine puisqu'on parle de ses
centres de formation les centres de
formation qui intéresse beaucoup les
politiques 1 à une arme importante
contre le chômage on l'a compris il ya
donc ce plan 500 une formation plan
lancé par le gouvernement voulu par
françois hollande qui a pour objectif
d'atteindre le million de demandeurs
d'emploi formé d'ici à la fin de l'année
un milliard d'euros a été confié aux
régions travaillent avec pôle emploi
afin de faire le point sur ce plan le
chef de l'état était à montigny le
bretonneux c'était le 12 septembre
dernier dans les locaux et d'ifo coop
l'institut de formation commerciale
permanente présentation de ce centre de
formation avec nicolas kerry à 8
250 stagiaires formés l'an passé
cinquante intervenants pour une
quinzaine de formations métiers le
nouveau centre ifo coop est implantée à
montigny le bretonneux depuis septembre
2015 avec pour objectif un retour à
l'emploi rapide et pour y parvenir une
seule formule magique 50% du temps en
entreprise 50% en formation
le format des formations ifo cops et
quatre mois en centre de formation est
une application concrète de quatre mois
en entreprise ça fait partie du cursus
de chercher et de trouver son entreprise
nous l'objectif ce n'est pas une
formation pour un stage c'est une
formation pour à l'emploi web digital
gestion ressources humaines ou encore
comptabilité le choix de formation est
conséquent à saint quentin en yvelines
et répond aux besoins des entreprises
locales peu importe l'âge ou les
diplômes le plus important se trouve
ailleurs pour les intéressés les plus
jeunes auront 21 22 ans il est
indispensable pour entrer à l'ifop
d'avoir au moins un an d'expérience
professionnelle ça c'est vraiment le
préalable indispensable pour tout le
monde sur certains métiers on va
demander une expérience professionnelle
ou non préalable sur d'hôtel pourrait
être plus courte mais peut être
compensée par un niveau bac un niveau
bac +2 en fonction des qualifications
requises a vécu à l'issue de la
formation
ce qui est récurrent chez toutes les
personnes encore une fois c'est vraiment
la motivation la détermination le projet
professionnel et l'adéquation avec le
marché du travail bien sont en l'espace
d'un an plus de 200 inscrits à l'ifocop
de saint quentin en yvelines ont
retrouvé un emploi un chiffre qui
pourrait être amplifiée avec le plan
500000 formation supplémentaire mis en
place par le gouvernement
erwan le gars qui est conseiller
communautaire pour l'emploi à saint
quentin en yvelines ce plan en cinq cent
mille formation et il sert à quelque
chose alors profitez-en mois déjà
c'est très bien que chef d'état se fait
venue et anti mais belle opération de
com bravo surtout qu'il a quand même
passé deux minutes à nous expliquer que
alstom me fallait que l'état redresse
cette entreprise lors de leurs
déplacements c'est mon dossier du jour
c'était donc réagit donc c'est plutôt un
coup de com que s'occuper des 500 milles
en tout cas ça a le mérite d'exister et
puis le nombre de gouvernements se
succèdent et puis on parle toujours du
plan de formation je pense que
réellement il va falloir prendre cette
opération à bras le corps et s'en
occuper valérie pécresse au niveau de la
région en a pris la teneur et à a mis en
place vraiment des actions pérennes sur
saint quentin nous ne sommes pas
habilités au niveau de la formation
professionnelle mais moi je crois que
sur les 500 milles en france c'est une
belle chose je pense qu'il fait beaucoup
plus ambitieux que ça réellement et
travailler sur du long terme voir le
modèle qui existe en suisse en allemagne
parce qu'il ya des belles réussites et
c'est gagnant gagnant enfin je n'ai pas
le temps là de l'expliquer mais une
entreprise qui prend un apprenti et là
c'est la formation continue c'est encore
autre chose de toute façon l'entreprise
et gagnant puisque à la former un jeune
qui derrière retrouvera aura un emploi
normalement dans la même entreprise et
perd prix volera de ses propres rêves
voilà puisqu'on parlait de formation va
faire une escale à présent à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines où il se trouve l'institut
supérieur de management de l'université
ça des livres à travers cette mention
depuis 2010 des formations de niveau
licence et de niveau master haussmann
vendeurs des camille lambert
elodie 34 ans est l'une des 1300
étudiants de l'institut supérieur de
management après une dizaine d'années en
tant que directrice de magasin la jeune
femme a décidé de se tourner vers une
carrière de drh sans expérience dans le
domaine sa seule solution était de
reprendre ses études en alternance et la
jeune étudiante ne regrette pas son
choix très très positif je savais que la
charge de travail serait assez intense
donc j'étais préparée psychologiquement
voilà en plus du fait de reprendre les
études après 10 en mai mais bon ça massa
m'a pas fait peur je pense que quand on
est motivé qu'on a un projet vraiment
tête
on fait abstraction de des contraintes
et puis et puis avec un taux de chômage
de 23 4% chez les jeunes de 15 à 24 ans
l'apprentissage est un axe primordial de
la politique du gouvernement de françois
hollande c'est aussi une demande des
entreprises qui souhaitent que les
étudiants et déjà une expérience
professionnelle à la sortie de leur
cursus une demande à laquelle répond
l'iace m depuis maintenant six ans
certains nos étudiants peuvent faire
trois années d'expérience
professionnelle donc ce qu'il y avait
effectivement particulièrement ensuite
bien placé pour pouvoir être recrutés et
pour les entreprises
ça permet justement de former des jeunes
et ensuite c'est une genre de
pré-embauche parce qu'ensuite ils
peuvent garder ce qui
identifie comme étant suffisamment bon
suffisamment adapté à ce dont ils ont
besoin et les entreprises sont plutôt
satisfaits sur les 500 entreprises
partenaires de l'institut supérieur de
management plusieurs étudiants en
alternance sont recrutés directement à
la sortie de leurs études
et pour conclure sur cette thématique du
jour la question était offres d'emploi
demandeurs d'emploi est-ce que ça match
à saint quentin est-ce que ça match oui
c'est un match un match ça marche bien
oui ça marche bien maintenant on doit
aussi être vigilant sur l'avenir voilà
on a un état de fait on a fait un
constat sur le présent l'avenir gala il
ya des métiers d'avenir il faut être
vraiment fun gps et sur le territoire
merci d'être venus pour certains numéros
de 7,8 et qu elle nous passons
maintenant à l'agenda de la quinzaine
[Musique]
trois dates à noter dans vos agendas ya
tout d'abord le cycle d'ateliers de co
développement qui se poursuit à la cité
des métiers de saint quentin en yvelines
prochain rendez vous le 19 septembre de
18h à 20h autre atelier cette fois ci
sur le développement de la gestion
financière ce sera le jeudi 22 septembre
de 9h30 à 12h à la maison de
l'entreprise à montigny le bretonneux
puis nous en avons parlé aujourd'hui
l'opération saint quentin à l écoute des
dirigeants des drh jeudi 22 septembre de
8h30 à 10h à la maison de l'emploi à
deux plaisirs dirigeants drh qui
échangent avec les responsables de
l'agglomération pour faire connaître
leurs besoins il y en aura d'autres un
des rendez vous organisés dans les
prochaines semaines prochain 7,8 échos
ce sera le jeudi 29 septembre il sera
question de l'automobile le mondial de
l'automobile s'apprête à ouvrir ses
portes à paris de mercedes à renaud en
passant par fiat la plupart des grands
groupes sont implantés à saint quentin
en yvelines et il se prépare pour cet
événement à très bientôt sur notre
antenne
[Musique]